the chancellor is of course in
Washington at the moment for a meeting
of global Finance ministers where the
government received something of a
rebuke from the head of the
international monetary fund speaking to
reporters crystallina georgieva appeared
to welcome a potential u-turn on that
mini budget
our message to everybody not just to the
UK to everybody's at this time
fiscal policy should not undermine
monetary policy because if he does it
then the task of monetary policy becomes
only harder and it translates into the
necessity for even further increase of
rates and tightening Financial
conditions
so don't prolong the pain
make sure that actions are are coherent
and consistent and I do believe that
it is correct to be led by evidence so
if the evidence is that there has to be
a recalibration it is right for
governments to do so
totally U.S correspondent Mark Stone in
Washington so Mark the managing director
there the IMF implicitly saying to the
UK is it uh get your act together
yeah I mean the beginning of what she
what she was saying there uh she made a
point of stressing that she was
referencing everyone talking to the
world's uh economies but at the end it
was a clear reference to potential
u-turns in the UK and it's to be honest
she was addressing questions from
British journalists I was struck that as
the uh the man who was hosting the news
conference went around the room he took
one question from a journalist
representing the Middle East one
question from a journalist representing
Africa and so on but then three
questions from journalists representing
at the UK and that was because
um the no two ways about it the the uh
the unease with which people are
watching what's going on in the UK
cannot be underestimated here they are
Keen to discover what's happening what
Liz truss's plan is and to that end
um they want to know more and they're
not getting it certainly from the
chancellor because they're a key meeting
today at the G20 Finance ministers
meeting at which the heads of the banks
of all the G20 countries were present as
well quasi-quartang was not he chose to
to attend other meetings or needed to
attend other meetings instead we're not
quite clear what meetings those were
Andrew Bailey is the governor of the
bank of England he was in the meeting I
caught up with him very briefly
afterwards uh here's what he said
sorry how was the meeting
any reason why the chancellor wasn't
there that's a question
[Music]
would it have been helpful if the
chancellor was there governor
the context The Wider context to all
this uh of course aside from uh from
from Nations around the world Keen to
understand the British government
thinking on their on their economic
plans The Wider context is a a global
economy that's in a really bad way and I
think the chief executive of the
international monetary fund she really
outlined that the pandemic Ukraine
climate the cost of living a perfect
storm she said across the growth
forecast cut to 2.7 and a 25 chance that
Global growth could drop drop below two
percent uh in the next year one phrase
though in her opening remarks stuck out
to me and I think it was a phrase
directed at the UK she said a complex
type complex time like this requires
steady hands on the policy levers I I
asked her whether she believed the UK
government's hands were steady she
declined to answer okay Mark Stone in
Washington thank you